hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to death I still don't
know how to pronounce that if anybody
can help me I probably still won't
notice and I'll keep being an idiot but
we just saved and we only have one
horrible monstrosity coming after us or
at least that's what I imagined I don't
know if the other horrible monstrosity
is going to continue pursuing us but we
can always hope there's always hope now
is there anything else down there I
can't quite remember because this is
where I got the the yellow goo that
powers all the magical machinery here
well this is interesting am I supposed
to jump down well the idiot side of me
would say yes dive face-first into that
pit of death that's a great idea
markimoo but the more rational side of
me oh there was another one says that I
should probably drop this down there
because maybe it's needed and then
plunge face-first into death ow my
ankles but that's okay I got a health
pack okay someone going to the toilet
down there or the bathroom whatever part
of the world you call up [ __ ] hole you
know the Google [ __ ] hole alright I'm
gonna take this with me even though I
obviously don't need it you never know
and I feel a lot more powerful when I'm
using my telekinesis to scare away all
the enemies alright
okay I'm gonna be shocked if this
actually is something but what the hell
is this
what the hell is this why did the string
quartet decide to show up why is it wet
so many questions that won't be answered
why is there an underground cemetery by
the underground castle which is adjacent
to the underground mine there's so many
questions racing through my mind I
barely have time to think about butts
and dick and you know those are my
favorite things to think about okay okay
okay
still don't know why why why why any of
this why is any of this here and what
did I just see oh I don't need this get
out of here
all right so okay carrying on road oh
I'll lose you
yellow goose - I don't know why do I
have to name everything it doesn't need
a name I highly doubt that it likes to
be called yellow goose - I don't know
about that no I'm not giving you a voice
either [ __ ] you yellow goose - okay fine
yellow goose - and I are going on an
adventure
screw tiny box Tim I like it when it's
disgusting oblong and a weird color
that's my favorite friend okay where am
I going with this I've annoyed am I
supposed to drop down again like an
idiot all right let's do that
let's do that thing let's go down into
the death come on yellow goose - it's
gonna be fun oh no yellow goose - it's
somewhere I can't take you oh [ __ ] you
still write bye
I was really hoping that wasn't gonna be
a level transition now is gonna be an
idiot okay there is no going back now of
that I am sure no matter how hard I
struggle my sanity fades away as my
final thoughts sink into the darkest of
voids could it really be
is there even a possibility that this
woman was once my real mother um I
didn't make that connection I don't know
how you did but I suppose that's a
possibility I mean I do remember there
was something along the lines of how his
mother was I guess you know I didn't
connect the dots because I played that
like before I went to DC so it's been
two weeks of some of the finer details
of the story have been replaced with
dicks and more butts and now yellow
goose two of whom I hope gets many
animations and a plushie that's what a
yellow goose do deserves can i light
this yeah whoosh whap whoosh key oh
that's nice and definitely not just
stuck in the objects okay so now that I
got light
what can I just carry this with me oh my
god portable light even though the
flames are going right into my eyeballs
ow okay so we got a definite presence of
bones here [ __ ] a definite presence of
clones so does a mean a mother is about
mother Oh mother where art thou mother
was it with this rock where's a rock
here I mean more absurd questions have
been asked but that's pretty absurd
what's with this rock oh my god another
rock it's a clue if only yellow goose to
was here might be able to solve this
clue of the goo and you okay anyway oh
hello are you a pressure plate are you
feeling pressured do you need someone to
relieve the stress uh-huh okay so
there's gonna be some sort of a timing
thing where there's going to be
oh the rocks oh oh oh I knew it was a
clue yellow goo Stu can go suck a chode
is it no that's a pot but the rock
where's the rock I just had their wheel
found a rock who's gonna help me in my
endeavor good thing I don't pick this up
with my arms and use my psychic powers I
mean I guess you know all things
considered if you suddenly woke up and
had psychic powers you would probably
use them 24/7 to do effort solutely
everything even if your life was boring
in Monday and you do it anyway
okay that did it I'm a genius I'm one of
those Geno's that me if that Geno boy
oh I need to Oh huh so smart so smart at
me Geno boy Oh probably going die Geno
boy but that okay you daddy now why why
you burned me why you burned me Allie
okay these are not doors but they look
like the door that I transitioned
through yes further
god dammit can you stop you're worse
than the bear traps
flaming torch March I don't know I can't
do it oh hello dead dead body toddy good
so it stop it I can't deal
holy Jen your mother down here there one
of them uh mother mother's better than
brother mother but mother mother it is I
know why I'm in a rhyming mood hello hey
damn to death he died doing what he
loved alright anyway yes that's my
version of the dab yeah that's my dab
that's my new thing everyone do it
everyone go out and film themselves
doing it right now
just let me buy me what's with the
ominous music really no need
okay so we got another pressure plate
situation what is this open it opens
that out there okay so I need to put a
rock in here there's a lot of pressure
plates boy when they found out this
puzzle they were like oh it could one
put it everywhere okay so I got to find
a bunch of rocks
ah Oh a bunch of rocks how convenient
I'm so happy for myself and my big brain
I always knew that I was a smart okay
you stay there you don't move could
somehow I got to do this puzzle and I'm
pretty sure I'm gonna need this other
rock hey hands off dead dead dead that's
good name alright I should name
should I run damn plane elegantly I
agree
should I go forward or should I run back
I don't know what I'm supposed to do
houki not dead yet so you're good I
guess
all things considered oh god damn it is
this a dead end how much
where is she
or she is how do I get in there how do I
get in there I do that how do I do this
thing I don't know I don't know is there
another rock over here
I really like my rocks okay so I don't
think I was supposed to bring this here
maybe I don't know maybe I was
I'll come back for that rock if I need
it it's gonna slow me down if I need to
suddenly run which I'm pretty sure that
I might actually need to do in the
eventual future cuz suddenly running is
my favorite form of Xers where you at
mama mama mmm
didn't mean to make you cry please do ha
ha ha oh god damn it that scared the
piss out of me
whoops Oh God there was another way to
go over here oh I went the wrong way
oh I want the dumb way I went one of
those dumb ways I didn't even see that
other way to go is it still after me
alpha how close I don't know how much
progress it made how much away getting I
did hmm it's really kruseman wool whoo
good ha ha whoa thank heavens I dare
whoa okay okay okay hmm
that is uh that's an angry mama Liz I
know right okay
I just want my rock I just want my rock
mama let me play with my rock it's a
good rock and never did Noah no harm
it's big boulder molder from the x-files
I don't know
big big rock [ __ ] oh yeah that's how
that's the opposite of right Oh get run
I don't just start running your dick oh
jeez I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm a
gap ironic I got my rack I got my rock
I'm not moving fast but I got my rock
god damn it where the [ __ ] out and buy
the the dead dabber [ __ ] how the [ __ ]
was I supposed to go anywhere where the
[ __ ] am I supposed to go I don't see a
route blast
shut up where yeah oh jeez
hello how are you doing okay bye man you
are annoying but I guess I gots to love
you your ma mama sorry mom I got a new
mama and she's got a knife no you know
come on no no no no
right so how the hell this doesn't make
any good she's still behind me ah [ __ ]
the answer is yes the answer was yes
uh-huh ah jeez don't do that well I'm
dead the answer was yes
survey says she stabbed me up the butt
okay so I'll be back when I find a bit
more of a intelligent way to go around
all this wait a minute I just had a
thought okay I might be very dumb or I
might be less observant than I'd like
myself to be so okay so let me explain
this I just realized something
literally because in the last bit
I tried throwing a rock at that thing
but what I failed to realize is that
fence above it there's a gap and there
isn't a gap on any of these other ones
so I think what I'm supposed to do is
I'm supposed to take the rocks over
there I was close I was very close I
just didn't quite connect the dots I
take the rocks over there throw them
over come back to this area where the
first one's done and use my psycho
powers to pull them into where they're
supposed to be
now that the challenge is and let me
just double-check if there's only two
because there's three other rocks in
this area that I give you there's one on
dowels yeah okay so there's two I'll
thank you that was for good luck
okay so there's definitely two of them
that explains why over there there was
the health kits because they were
preparing me to run by her and just in
case she stabbed me anywhere in the butt
toll region okay so but down here what I
got to do is I got wasting all of my
juice
okay so she'll spawn but I can put these
over the yes I can okay and then put
them shoot them generally in the area
where I want them to go yeah that's the
[ __ ] yes okay hopefully I can get that
in the right spot and then take these
things
and then sneak by her and then get on
you out of here okay she's coming down
this way okay so she's just gonna look
at me okay we're gonna play we're gonna
play this game we're gonna play this
game do this come on you ain't got me
all right you got sick laughs [ __ ] a guy
got stuck on a lip [ __ ] [ __ ]
she's coming quick
but what the [ __ ] goddamn it [ __ ] it
step back stop being so mean to me ah
cut stop being mean to me why god dammit
that is the Dickey estict hell I've
dipped a lot of dong oh [ __ ] out stamina
okay over okay okay we got it we got it
I had to use my health potions but we
got oh hey hey friend
how you doing okay so I need to pull
this one over here well how's it that's
not stay good okay so got that here we
go got him okay
now we're free whoo okay man that took a
lot of effort that took a lot of effort
I don't know why I took so much but
maybe it's because of my incredible
incompetence every time I close my eyes
I dream of the Sun touching my ghostly
skin washing away my troubles under a
stream of bright cleansing light minutes
passed by only for me to realize that my
flesh appears as an endless plain of
scorched earth was pitch black blood
overflowing from each crack in this
broken body of mine an infernal pool
drawn from my own blood is devouring me
as my final cry wears off in a
collection of smothered screams is that
the same mom writing this that is out
there and only speaks in screams cuz
that was quite articulate and well
written and her dialogue is mostly argh
and ugh not that I'm criticizing teach
their own I mean everyone has their own
way who was that that bodies okay should
I do this
well that did nothing ah lovely I don't
know where there's gonna take me but I
hope it's somewhere with a save point
that would be lovely
it better have a save point over here
somewhere it better I'm gonna be post
you will find on the right in Haiti's
halls a spring a ghost Cyprus ghostly
cypress tree stand still beaconing each
descending soul to wash away their lives
but be warned for the spring fur it is
called the leg instead keep descending
and you will find yourself in another
spring with chill water flowing from the
pool of memory guarded by restless
Watchers they will ask you the reason of
your presence speak only true words with
fearless heart I am the son of Earth and
starry heaven but of heaven is my birth
this you know yourselves I am parched
with thirst and perishing give me
quickly chill water flowing from the
pool of memory
only then the rulers of this realm will
offer you water from the spring you will
unveil secrets in each and every drop of
this water as all other initiates have
before you and then you will finally
feast amongst the gods okay is this a
clue for me to do or is this a clue for
you to do I'm not sure which I'm
assuming that just summons the elevator
for up and down if it's necessary had
escaped thank you for breaking properly
do you have any kebabs
oh just jerky I need lots of health wait
what is this wait what is this whoa whoa
whoa okay well this seems uh Wow
big okay should I walk here is this safe
I don't feel safe
this is Hades Hall is that why the
castle was built down here cuz it's
built by demons from hell is this doom
the prequel okay it took only a moment
before she opened her mouth screaming in
agony as her broken jaw moved it
revealed an unspeakable horror of broken
teeth and twisted flesh Jakob dragged
her closer and on to her feet
for a moment I thought this sadist would
finally stop but my hope vanished when I
looked at his face and saw his lips
crack into a disturbing smile shortly
after as her shattered face laid on the
burning stove he started pouring the hot
oil the clotting blood dripping off her
hair the site was more than I could
handle all I could do at the time was
command my body to crawl senselessly
into the woods I was a coward so this is
the guy that loved the woman who was
married to Jacob over here who was an
[ __ ] and turned her into the monster
that she is I'm assuming that's all i
can assume because i know nothing else
what's over here
and should i even go over here because
there's a big obelisk type door not
obelisk something else that's really
profound and interesting and worthy of
good commentary on a let's plan and
makes people look smart and good and all
good a bear trap great I love everyone
all right all right whatever good at
least they're giving me health beside of
the bear trap those douche bags we got
here My Dear Colleague once again I'm
writing a new to express my deepest
admiration for everything that you have
offered to our society many people were
saved by your research while theirs
endured less suffering than they would
have otherwise being the only doctor in
this closed community has never been as
difficult every day is a struggle
between science and morality like a
child in an endless playground I
treasure our correspondence and I have
the utmost appreciation for your
continued support for it gives me the
strength to carry on I have once again
visited the
site to record anything that might help
us in our research one of the miners
revealed to me a strange coincidence
that took place at the time he said that
it was only a few days after their
discovery of an unusually solid
reformation of rocks in the minds of the
violent behavior broke out I suspect
some airborne substance was released
after the workers mistakenly chose to
excavate this material on my next visit
to the site I will collect some samples
and have them sent over to you
interesting I mean this is kind of like
a back and forth of the right timeline
to piece together exactly what is going
on here but is this part of the mine
this doesn't seem part of the mine that
seems part of some ancient ruins or
something like that like they can't have
excavated all of this castle
could they have Oh guess who's back okay
for many years now I have attempted to
open the gate to no avail I appear to be
missing the final piece of what
considered to be my greatest discovery
my latest research shows that a great
force of powers locked behind this gate
in ancient records seemed to be
confirming my findings the old reports
speak of some sort of portal to an
entirely different world but I have
reason to believe that this gate could
actually be an ancient mechanism to lead
a soul to enlightenment liberating it
from its corporeal shell to live forever
in eternity the gate requires some form
of external stimulus but I have yet to
be able to discover what that could be
what I do know is that it should be an
entity with great potential and if my
calculations are correct it could even
be a living thing a human being no less
if only I had more resources more
subjects to work with I'm confident I
would be able to unravel its secrets and
finally become truly immortal so your
calculations you did some algebra though
to be determined that it couldn't might
be a human I don't know if I'm supposed
to believe that god damn it I gotta go
back man if I'd have never gone down
this path I wouldn't never spawn
okay cutscene hot fine yeah my face why
you slap me who are you you dr.
Rosenberg oh oh thank you my mom oh
don't
what are you what are you doing
okay I guess I'll just take a nap here
oh no I'm awake now that was a good nap
okay so he's dead is that the doctor is
that the doctor after the yellow goose
do got to him I don't know I'm talking
about pretty sure I'm not talking about
anything okay so am i this being of
great potential is that what I'm
supposed to discover here hmm is that
what we're uh supposed to be realizing
here am I supposed to go over here and
whoop and do a thing with a thing over
here yep oh hello ah who are you what
are you doing here I was filled with joy
when the professor informed me that both
mother and child were safe but this
feeling did not last because in my
despair I'd signed everything that was
placed in front of me and it was too
late when I finally realized that my
newborn son was supposed to be his
guinea pig a nightmare broke out in my
dreams a thunderstorm of human cries my
son's plea for help pierced my mind and
unclouded my thought I have to put an
end to this before it goes all lost so
are you the guy that loved the lady who
was turned into a demon who is also my
mother am I your son because you had a
love affair with her while she was
married to Jacob who was a beast and
turned her into a monster is that what
I'm supposed to piece together from all
this so I got the two halves of the
doodad I think yep sure did ow
ah not my hands I use my telekinesis
okay I got it
well fancy are we getting close to the
end or something we might be huh okay
just had to think about it for a second
whoa
that is bright who is there oh hello
that's a neat effect okay I'm just gonna
stare at this I'm pretty sure it's great
for my vision yep blind oh okay
Oh Oh
either I'm turning invisible or I'm
disintegrating oh those end of episode 1
and yet there's more to come in the
future okay I like this a lot
I don't want anyone to think otherwise I
mean obviously this is an indie game so
you got to give it the indie game credit
like a little less polish than in some
games but even for what it was this was
fantastic I like this a lot it was a
return to the old amnesia style of
horror with a lot of amnesia inspiration
obviously but it was a return to that
and it was actually very good that John
guy man see these guys like they did a
lot of stuff just by themselves with
this accustomed engine if that is that
is fantastic but either way I like this
a lot my only criticism was the save
system I think that could have been
refined just a little bit but from what
they got here there's a lot of cool
stuff here and there's a lot of pieces
of paper that I did not find in this
there's a lot of Secrets that I did not
locate this is a good game it was very
scary at times it really got me even
though after you saw the monster was
kind of like oh you're just a bumbling
AI but even so there was a lot of
potential here so I am very much looking
forward to the future of this game and
the other episodes and I will definitely
play them when they come out but let me
know what you guys thought of it down in
the comments below give the developers
some love show them some support and
maybe even get this game for yourself to
try to find the secrets that I didn't
get so let me see if there's anything at
the end of the credits and then I'll say
goodbye okay so that's all there is so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
why am i carrying the demon book that
turned everything in the darkness I'm
starting to see well alright then you
dick back what in a